Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast.
Just before Friday.
Yeah,
it's going on.
I'm going to get complaints from my neighbors cause I got the fucking door open.
I don't give a shit cause it's hot today.
Oh,
it's Aha.
I'll tell you it's a hot one,
you know.
Um,
it's fucking hot as shit.
But I live in California and I'm not running the fucking AC.
I'm,
I'm doing my plot.
You know,
I'm doing my part for the fishy,
for the water that we steal or whatever.
Uh,
you know,
I'm fucking,
I'm doing what I can,
but saw it as a,
that that's all you can do.
It's all you can tell.
You know,
you just do what she can.
Okay.
Just hope that the people at the top that don't give a fuck about anybody but
themselves in their bulls.
We'll,
we'll maybe let something trickled down to you.
That's right to you will.
Um,
yeah,
I've been,
uh,
I'm trying to do my part,
you know,
I was really fucking into that shit for a while.
Then I just like,
you know what?
Nobody else gives a fuck.
I'm not trying.
And then,
then I've Kinda,
I fucking grown up and I got out of it.
I've sworn off bottled water.
I'm not doing any more.
I walk around like,
like a fucking adult toddler.
I got a giant fucking thermos and I fill that thing up before I leave.
And then I just go out and,
uh,
I'm going to take that thing on the road.
Me,
I'm going to sip from it though.
There's no way I'm going to sit,
you know,
drink from it when I'm on stage,
when I do my shows,
because it's got like this red dog dick tip,
not get heckled enough as it is,
but uh,
you know,
you see that shit enough bottled water is used every year and thrown out to go
around the whole fucking world or something.
I think that's just our country.
I don't know what this Hippie told me.
It wasn't even a hippy with something on the discovery channel.
And um,
so I'm trying not to do that and then I'm taking quicker showers,
basically hosed myself down like a dog.
And then I shut off the water than I did.
I sold myself up.
Relaxed ladies,
try it out.
Try to compose yourself here and then when I'm done doing that,
then I just rinse myself off and itself cause I'm sick of people.
Yeah,
you'll actually,
you take a bell could use Liz would are there any for you if you stay in it up,
it's like,
dude,
a bath.
You're laying in your own filth.
You know what I mean?
It's fucking gross.
Unless you're a hot broad,
but some fucking bubble shit going on.
You're in there reading your little fucking book about the prince that's going
to touch the lady's clam after they kiss the horse with the frog there.
Right.
Then it's just gross.
You're just a,
you're a fucking animal.
Okay.
You know it's clean water until you get in it.
Then you're just sitting there.
There's a lot of shit with that.
You know,
people watch,
you know,
wash your hands after you take it pissed.
It's like,
why don't you fucking wash your hands before you do it?
Okay.
You're not opening doors with your Dick,
are you?
Unless you like Lenny Kravitz,
you squatted down during your solo and your fucking Dick came out of fucking
awesome.
Is that big?
Shout out to Lenny Kravitz having a great fucking rock and roll moment.
He fucking was doing a show I think over in Sweden and he's wearing leather
pants cause he's a fucking rock star and he squats down during the solo in his
fucking Dick flopped out.
And according to my wife who told me,
right,
I don't give a fuck.
I go fuck up.
My wife looks at Lenny's Dick.
Why wouldn't you if you're abroad,
why wouldn't ya?
Um,
you know,
a fucking a one of those fucking pop stars.
Clams came out.
You'd think,
I'm not looking.
Remember when Beyonce fell down the stairs,
you remember that you were waiting for a teddy that come out.
You weren't concerned about whether she got concussed.
Where are you?
You were waiting for an iconic teddy to flop out.
It has not happened as far as I know,
since Janet Jackson,
there was all that skanky wardrobe malfunction and that it was like,
you forgot that you weren't wearing panties and fucking Brittany would get out
and show her fucking clam.
You know what I mean?
That Tallahassee fucking Twat that she has.
I mean,
that's not sexy.
She's one of those dirty feet chicks.
He's one of those chicks walking in the fucking liquor store without fucking
sandals on.
And that's a mother too.
And I know I'm being harsh.
I know I'm judging her,
but you know,
ladies,
if you,
if you have filthy feet,
got dirty feet,
let's try to keep the titties and the sports bra this summer.
All right?
However,
if you clean,
you know,
and you roll down a flight of stairs,
by all means,
let it,
let them come up.
You know,
give somebody a show.
That's all I'm saying.
You know,
I'm trying to bring people together here.
So anyways,
his fucking Dick flopped out in the middle of his fucking solo in front of a
crowd of people.
He's Planning Guitar Solo as a rock star wearing leather pants.
And his dick flops out.
I mean,
come on.
How do you,
how does it get better than that?
As a man?
How can you be crushing it any harder?
I'll tell you are how you actually have a fucking you dick pierced.
You know what I mean?
That makes it even better.
Which evidently he did.
This guy's Dick was actually weighted down and it still flopped up number on
last Monday when I was talking about how dicks around in the fucking locker room
while they're out at a Lenny Kravitz concept too.
So if he easily offended,
if you don't got the quick twitch and you can't move your head out of the way
quickly,
you might not want to go for those front row seats.
You know?
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I don't talking about,
I'm talking about Lenny's Dick coming out good for him.
And you know when anybody's offended by that fuck that they took 20 years for
that guy.
He's been around since 1988 what am I talking about?
This guy's been around for 27 years without incident,
I think once every three decades.
If you,
Dick Flops out during the performance,
what do you,
what are you going to do?
It's bound to happen,
right?
You know,
somebody is going to,
oh,
I have what it happened over in Europe.
They don't give a shit,
right.
Probably happens to them all the time.
That fucking James is so tight over there.
All those tight as Jane's wherein fucking people over there in Europe.
I don't know what the deal is.
I think after World War Two,
if your pants were too saggy,
someone would come by and just snatch them like a pair of warmup.
Fucking sweaty.
You know,
those guys were in the NBA,
right?
Some tearaways.
So the people over there in Europe,
you know,
their grandparents came back and they had to wear a tidy fucking jeans
and then their kids did it.
And now that kids kids do it and they're just walking around with those tight
fucking jeans
all up on the nuts.
Um,
I know what I'm talking about.
I actually got the fucking,
um,
so I got the door open here.
I've got a screen door for my,
from my office here.
Um,
underrated the fucking screen door.
It's a Goddamn game changer,
you know,
tell us a very white trash,
which is what I am,
you know,
white trash.
I'm a trashy sort of individual.
Um,
uh,
just killing it right now.
But,
uh,
I just got to watch about this Dick Carson really loud because of my fucking
neighbors.
What are they going to do?
It's a great thing about order order and a house owning a house.
It's like,
what are you going to,
I own the house.
What are you gonna do?
You're going to call the landlord.
That's me.
All right.
I know what some of you guys are saying.
Oh No,
the bank is because you still owe them money.
No,
I don't.
Yeah.
Cons.
I fucking pay this thing off.
I own it.
This is my fucking hunk of shit.
Gradually fixing this fucking God damn house,
man.
I swear to God,
it's,
it's haunted with repairs every fucking time.
I think.
I think I'm,
I'm turning the corner.
You know,
I'm getting around the corner and something good's going to happen.
Something else fucking happens in,
uh,
AH,
Christ.
I got fucking termites in my garage.
I got this other fucking,
I didn't want to talk about it,
you know,
but I got a screen door.
Okay.
Last month I did not have a screen door.
I'm not going negative here.
I'm going to stay positive.
So anyways,
I uh,
yeah.
Uh,
we finished punching up episode six of F is for family.
Had a nice 12 hour day yesterday.
Um,
oh my God.
I was a whiny bitch at the end of it.
You know,
we had it still.
We finished it and we had to do a couple of other things.
I was like,
Ooh,
ow fucking baby.
I've been spoiled.
Spoiled as a goddamn comedian.
Live in the life.
Speaking to Comedians,
speaking of Comedians,
um,
core mccown friend of the Monday morning podcast.
Where the fuck did it go?
I had everything ready.
Oh,
there is,
I can never,
I never,
I always think I'm going to have everything on command here on demand.
I don't know what it is.
Um,
friend of the Monday morning podcast,
cigar buddy of mine,
um,
cohost of the podcast insensitive and sensitivity training with Rosebowl
tailgate.
Legend Joe Barton.
Nick the godfather of the Rose Bowl tailgate and uh,
also member of the all things comedy network court.
Mccown has a new album coming out tomorrow called live from Pearl Street.
Uh,
you can preorder it today or get it tomorrow at court.
Mccown dotcom@cortmsmallccapitalcown.com or all things comedy.
It was recorded in La Jolla San Diego.
And the album has been getting great reviews by comics who have had an early
listener.
Listen.
And um,
and that's it man.
Check it out.
Support the all things comedy network,
checkout court.
Mccount good friend of mine.
Um,
and listen to the and sensitivity training podcast if you can.
All right though.
You done with your commercial?
Yeah,
it's sort of a commercial.
So anyways,
uh,
what are we going to talk about here?
Oh,
we got to talk about the Tom Brady emails.
Did you guys read the fucking Tom Brady emails?
Did you,
did you sit down,
you know,
put on a nice comfortable sweater.
You know when that fits halfway over your hands and you picked up your coffee
mug with both fucking hands and just settle down to read the gossip?
Yeah.
Well,
if you did,
you've lost all respect with me and tell your father that he didn't raise a man.
I didn't read a model.
What kind of a fucking mad sits down and reads leaked emails of another man.
What are you doing?
Huh?
Wait.
What?
What the how fucking pathetic is your God damn life.
How jealous are you a Tom Brady that you're going to get in there and see him
talking,
talking to GSL about the fucking dog food he's got to go get.
You know what I mean?
Grow the fuck up.
What'd you want somebody doing that to you?
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
How the fuck did he get air pressure?
Now we're reading his emails.
What are we going to do next?
Give out the guy's social security number.
I can't wait for this whole fucking thing to turn around.
All right,
this guy's getting burned at the fucking steak and eventually there's going to
be nothing left to burn and then the media is slowly going to come around like,
Whoa,
we're referring to Tom Brady.
Skip Bayless is already doing it.
Skip Bayless,
who's never made a good point in his life somehow was on ESPN.
who literally does is show where if one guy says you need air to breathe,
he will argue the other side just to keep some sort of,
just to keep the plates spinning,
just to keep the excitement going.
Skip Bayless,
how that guy is in hosting the family feud or,
or wheel of fortune.
Okay.
You know why that one where you punched the thing when it pops up,
whatever the card sharks as what he looks like he should be doing.
Even he knows even he knows that there's something rotten out there in
Indianapolis.
There's something going on there in Baltimore too.
Horrific fucking cities.
Absolutely horrific cities.
Baltimore,
you know your city's fucked up when they make the wire there.
Right?
That's a done deal.
I don't even need to talk any more about that city.
You know what I mean?
And then out in Indianapolis or what do they have in Indianapolis?
They got the apple is 500 and a giant Klan rally every year.
You know
Jesus Christ.
You want to read some interesting,
why don't you read about somebody who plays for the Pacers.
Okay?
You're dead center in one of the widest fucking states ever with one of the
highest clan fucking memberships.
Dude,
Indiana.
That is a place as a fucking white guy,
if you want to be a complete fucking maniac and not be held accountable,
that's what I've learned.
Gemara say,
my hat is off to you.
My hat is off to you.
You pick the city,
man,
he picked this fucking state.
They would.
If you're going to conduct yourself the way you conduct yourself,
okay?
And I tell you right now,
I know you got a walk in closet bigger than my house,
full.
All kinds of habit dash Regan shiny fucking shoes and pocket squares.
But you're not fooling this balding redhead.
Oh No,
you are not,
sir.
I know who you are.
You know,
why?
Cause I used to drink and Chelsea,
Massachusetts,
I met guys like you.
Oh,
gives a fuck.
Football season is upon us.
It's August.
Everybody Bump Toto Bodo put it up,
put in a battery,
suck my fucking Dick.
It's here.
It's beginning.
And God bless all those football fans that are such maniacs,
like especially Steeler fans who are out there fucking at the Steelers training
camp bugging,
you know Randy Bauman,
you know,
on Wd v e and Pittsburgh.
All right.
Oh by the way,
by the way,
Pittsburgh people you might want to watch after his for family,
you might want to watch F is for family.
You might recognize something.
There's a little teaser.
You might recognize something on that show.
I gave a little nod to fucking steel town there,
which has now become computer town down there at the stacks.
Let's go down at forever 21.
Um,
anyways,
what am I talking about here?
Yeah,
so football season's coming up.
Um,
I actually went to a party recently and it was this couple that Nia and I know
and they're a,
they're moving back to New York.
You know,
they,
uh,
one of them got this awesome acting gig and all that.
Just fuck it.
Oh,
by the way.
And they got the cutest fucking kid ever,
right?
Little redheaded boy.
And His dad is a drummer and his mother is a singer.
So he's got,
you know,
he's got the gift and he fucking loves drums,
right?
So he's fucking Waylon on these drums.
He's like two years old Whalen on these drums.
And uh,
I don't,
I don't know what the next thing,
you know,
I'm fucking sitting there with my iPhone and I'm showing him Moby Dick,
the fucking a,
that didn't sound good at toddler and then Dick in the same sentence.
No,
it didn't.
The song,
a led Zeppelin Song,
the Moby Dick,
the drum solo,
and uh,
the one for Royal Albert Hall,
when he's on that maple kit and I showed on,
the first thing I did was I showed him the clip of Keith Carlock that my wife
took when we saw steely Dan and he kept going,
play it again,
play it again.
And then when Keith would be going completely nuts on the drums,
you know,
like the third time he just looked two years old,
just looked up to me and he just goes,
wow.
Where you would say,
wow,
you know,
the whole thing was great.
But when he built it up to like the,
the,
the peak,
this kid was going nuts.
So my guy you liked and we watched it like eight times in a row,
he kept going play it again,
play it again.
Riveted like most kids is sitting there watching uh,
the tumbleweeds or whatever the cuff fuck you call those things.
All those things that didn't talk and everybody thought it made your kid weird.
There was a blue one and a red one,
not the M and.
M's,
they look like a Barbara Papa's,
but they were more like robotic teletubbies.
Yeah.
We got like,
I worked it out teletubbies.
So anyways,
uh,
he's fucking riveted to that.
So I go,
I'm going to show you this John Barnum thing.
And uh,
he just fucking got just totally enamored with it.
Um,
it was fucking awesome.
It was awesome.
Cause I know that kid,
that kid's going to be a great drummer.
So,
uh,
actually before they leave,
I'm going to try to find,
you can find it anymore.
They don't even make DVDs.
I got to get them a DVD copy of that so they can pop that in.
You know,
how cool is it to have a kid like that?
That's babysitting.
You fucking put in led Zeppelin and the kids loving it at two years old as
opposed to some fucking kitty shit that's just playing one of those songs that
slowly drives you mad.
Right?
This is the song that does and that's why you got to get them into sesame
street.
Right?
Sesame street has all one,
all that fucking subtle humor for adults.
They actually realized that there was going to be a parent around,
but somewhere along the line that fucking art has really dropped off.
They do it with movies though,
one of those toy story movies and that type of ship.
But when they just make something just straight up for kids,
um,
like literally the drugs you have to do to be on to somehow fucking get through
it and knowing full well the kid wants to,
you know,
you can get through it once,
but knowing that the kid wants to see it again,
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
Oh Jesus.
All right,
let's do a,
let's do a little bit of advertising here for this week.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of only one read this week.
It's weird.
It's almost a,
it was like,
I need to read these a little straighter.
Maybe we'll get some more advertising.
Blue Apron,
everybody.
Blue Apron.
Uh,
it's okay.
You can admit it.
The last thing anyone anyone wants to do after work is wait in line at the
grocery store,
Schlep home and cook a complicated meal and expensive,
unhealthy takeout is hardly better.
That's where the new service blue apron comes in.
Blue Apron delivers farm fresh ingredients and step by step recipes to your
home,
allowing you to create healthy,
handcrafted meals at home without going to the grocery store for less than 10
bucks per meal.
Blue Apron sense you fresh ingredients,
perfectly proportioned making cookie cookie making cooking.
There's a Freudian slip.
I'm like,
fuck the vegetables.
I want a cookie.
Oh,
it's an ice cream making cooking healthy meals,
really easy and fun.
No trips to the grocery store and no waste from unused ingredients.
Plus you learn to cook with special specialty ingredients that are normally hard
to find.
Blue Apron is perfect for date night.
Jesus crisis as long blue apron is perfect for date night cooking with friends
and they even offer family plans with kid friendly ingredients so the whole
family can eat well and have fun preparing meals together.
Next paragraph.
Each balanced meal is 500 700 calories per serving and so your tastes so tasty.
You'd never know.
Cooking takes half an hour.
Shipping is flexible.
Hawes and free and menus are always knew they won't send the same meal twice.
They work around your schedule and dietary preferences and blue apron experts
source only the best seasonal ingredients for incredible meals like Salmon,
Caesar's salad,
salmon season,
salads,
sensational and flat iron steaks with buttermilk,
smashed purple potatoes and terragon beans.
You'll cook incredible meals and be blown away by the quality and the freshness.
Blue Apron.
It's a better way to cook.
All right,
finally,
here we go.
This is how you get it.
Check out this week's menu and get your first two meals for free by going to
blue apron.com/berbee you are my treat really.
The first two meals are on me now.
The Ron Blue Apron.
Uh,
when you go to blue apron.com/burpee you are are,
they should really get to the meat of the audit there.
No Pun intended.
Uh,
you don't have time to cook and in order to become a fat fuck right,
this is the way to do it.
Come home.
You throw the shit in the pot,
it's done.
You eat it.
Stare at the TV,
you're not off,
and you go right back to work the next day.
Next thing you know the hot broad down the hall,
you want a bank.
So I said,
what are you doing?
It's something that the shame of your mother's desk.
No Bitch,
I got it
right and shelter,
you get apps too.
They'll take the elevator right down to the fucking,
what do you call it?
The fucking you collected there.
We'll start at the start at the top floor.
If you want to get more blow jobs guys,
I'm telling you,
you got to get abs because what happens is they'll kiss on those two,
which is the two easiest ones to get.
But then if it starts smoothing out,
they can't get up that hill.
They can't get over the hill.
He his stomach,
he got to flatten that fucker up,
you know?
Then they go down and flow number two,
floor number three and then they spend the night and those,
those two long ones,
that's like the slide,
you know
right into the power switch.
Ah,
God pill really has it come to that?
What it is it come to that.
It's always been there.
I've always been a dick joke comic.
All right.
So speaking of that,
how you guys doing on your diet?
How are you guys doing?
Get Your beach body by September.
Just like me with global warming,
you can walk around shirtless until October.
It's phenomenal.
Walk around shirtless,
you know,
go up and hug a walrus.
That for some reason is in your backyard.
Now who knows?
Why is it there?
I don't know.
Did you check out the new iPhone seven [inaudible] I should talk.
I get to six.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
this week I need to get down to a buck 74.
As of this morning,
I was one 75.2,
but having a rough week,
you know,
I even played hockey this weekend.
I'm still,
I'm thinking I'm starting.
My Body's getting used to not Busan and me eating well,
which is scary because that means if I stopped doing this and I go back to the
toxic,
Shit's going to be a problem.
Like the other night,
uh,
a buddy of mine,
um,
he,
he was every Tuesday night,
right?
He makes some food and he's got this,
uh,
you know,
he makes the move and pictures there.
He makes the talkies.
So he,
he has like his son comes over and uh,
you know,
when he shows,
a bunch of his friends,
I come over a couple of other people and they fucking screen movies or whatever.
So I went over there and he had burgers and fries and I'm going,
Oh shit,
I didn't eat dinner.
And I was like fuck it.
So I grabbed the Turkey Burger,
I had French fries and onion rings.
Not too many,
but I had him and then I was thinking,
well I'm playing hockey later,
I'll fucking burn this off.
And all I did was I went out and hockey and I literally felt like I ate one of
my skates and we played at this new fucking place that has was the rink was the
size of like Olympic level ice like the European iceman.
I fucking loved it.
I loved it cause I was actually able to stick handle for a good second and a
half before somebody took it away from me.
Cause those smaller rinks,
people are just on top of you.
So I liked it and,
and everybody else was like,
oh my good.
It was so fucking tired.
It's like really I wasn't,
you know,
some about not handling the puck and just gliding around,
you really keep your wind.
Um,
I was bad.
I went out my first shift,
they went out and I fucking skated at my,
my own guy,
you know,
made a move right over the blue line.
And I just looked at him as he came right at me and he was looking down at the
puck and we fucking slammed into each other like a couple of toddlers.
Um,
and of course everyone's like,
hey,
you know,
just embarrassing myself but I'm,
I'm on,
I'm not out there to get better at hockey.
Who's kidding?
Who?
I'm out there like a total la fucking plastic phony.
I'm out there to burn calories.
So anyways,
I'm one 75.2,
so I'm going to hit it hard the next couple of days,
get myself down one 74 and then Dan,
it gets exciting.
Then it gets excited cause my fight and weights about one 71,
one 72,
although there's pooch,
you know,
I'm trying to up the fucking protein,
you know what I mean?
Um,
and I've been doing this workout that Burt fucking cry.
Bert Kreischer tweeted to me,
um,
I think it was from men's health magazine.
It was like improving your grip strength and I'm telling you dude,
I've done a lot of different shit and it's like,
yeah,
whatever,
whatever this shit fucking works.
Um,
I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to read we it retweeted or whatever.
Um,
basically to improve your grip strength,
which helps you,
I guess lift heavier shit.
I don't know what,
I'm just trying to be able to do more pull ups,
this fucking thing.
It's really cool.
So the first thing you do is you hang from the Ia,
you hang from the,
your chin up bar in the pullup position.
You try to do it two sets for a minute straight,
whatever.
If you can only do 10 seconds next time,
try 15,
you work your way up.
So once you do that,
which I've been able to do,
then you do it where you hanging from for a minute,
one hand on the pull up bar,
the other one you hang a rag or a towel over the,
uh,
the chin up bar and then you help at one hand is holding the towel.
The other one's holding the,
uh,
the pull up bar.
So most of your,
most of your,
um,
strength is coming from the thing.
Obviously the hand holding the uh,
the pull up bar and you get to the point where you can do that for a minute with
each hand.
Right?
So I got to that point.
So now I'm to the next one.
This one,
now you just hang from the fucking pull up bar by one arm for a minute and I'll
see how that goes.
Hopefully I don't pull my arm out on my socket,
but I've noticed that,
you know,
climbing the rope,
the peg board,
all of that type of shit is getting a,
it's getting easier.
Also,
you know,
I'm shaving down the fucking ham,
so,
uh,
I dunno.
That's what the fuck I've been doing oatmeal every fucking day,
guys,
oatmeal,
banana,
and I'm doing a little bit less oatmeal and I'm scrambling to fucking eggs with
nothing on them for the protein or whatever.
And I got to tell you is bland as that is when I'm done eating it,
I feel like I could run through a fucking wall though.
My wife's been doing this thing where she makes oatmeal,
then she puts some peanut butter in there and then some berries.
And I'm telling you,
dude,
you fucking eat like that.
You feel like a superhero.
And then of course you go to pick up a box if you my age than you,
you know,
you feel like it's 600 years old,
but when you walk over to the box,
you feel phenomenal.
Um,
so anyways,
oh,
so as I was mentioned,
so I went to that party,
right.
I'm all over the map has always,
um,
with the couple that was,
you know,
is moving away with the fucking soon to be rock stars Sun,
right?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I met somebody over there that was a big time Auburn Fan.
And,
uh,
he was just going off talking about,
you know,
are they really got a shot this year,
being good and all that type of shit.
And uh,
he me where there was an Auburn bar and um,
I dunno man,
I know I'm an Lsu guy,
but I think Auburn's my second team in the SCC,
I just like both those teams because they have a huge rivalry with Alabama.
I know everybody in the SCC AIDS Alabama.
I didn't even hate Alabama.
They just,
just fun to root against them.
My,
come on man,
I'm a fucking,
uh,
what do you call it?
A carpet bagger or whatever.
I'm not from the south would have fucked do I get off picking a team?
Right.
If I was like a,
a typical Yankee Fan,
I go down there and I'd be like,
oh look it a little bit about,
you know,
cause they don't like a challenge,
you know what I mean?
A mets fan,
right?
Mets fan would come down,
they'd be like,
Fuck Alabama.
Um,
so what,
I'm a red sox fan,
so I always fuck the people that are on top,
which is hilarious at this point.
The amount of money that was a red sox fan,
a red sox spent.
I know I'm a total hypocrite,
but it's just fun to root against Alabama because Alabama is supposed to win.
So let's gets boring after awhile.
Um,
although I am psyched that um,
that saving was able to,
uh,
bring the program back cause it was once bear Bryant went away.
That was a rough number of years.
You know,
it's funny.
Do you know how I always remember Nick Saban's name?
Cause I always forget it.
I always remember when I was at the Lsu game and the whole student section,
they would chant,
fuck you say then fuck you Saban and I,
for some reason that just stuck with me.
So whenever I'm,
I'm coming up to his name,
I start slowing down the sentence and then I hear that students section chanting
that,
how fucking weird is that?
Well,
whatever,
I'm a weird guy.
What do you want from me?
Um,
all right,
so we're coming up on 28 minutes here.
I'm finally getting my Internet fixed today,
man.
Um,
I went on this website that somebody told me about to see what,
what I was getting.
If you get in like 40 to 60 megabytes per minute download,
like that's like the bare minimum,
I guess even that kind of sucks.
I don't know shit about this.
I was getting 0.3.
I haven't had like dial up.
I just had regular old fucking Internet.
I didn't realize it.
So uploading these podcasts has been taken forever.
So now I said fuck this and um,
I just got the,
I went to a different company.
Now I'm going to get 300 megabytes of fucking minute.
I want to like that,
that fucking Internet you get at the hotel.
Whenever I record one at the hotel,
I go to upload it and just goes fucking way done.
My heart.
What does it do,
Bill fucking gun,
right?
I do it here.
I'm sitting around for like four hours screaming at my computer.
Ooh,
fuck it.
Hey computers like a goddamn baby.
All right.
So anyways,
that is the,
uh,
the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Hope you guys having a good week.
If you're not,
it's already Thursday.
You probably listened to this on the ride home.
You only got one more day.
Fuck it.
Right.
Have a good time this weekend.
Summer's almost over and joy it.
Have a good weekend.
You cunt.
And I will talk to you on Monday and Monday.
I have a,
uh,
I have a big announcement that I'm not going to be able to do on the podcast
because I have to wait until nine o'clock at night,
I think east coast time,
which would be 6:00 PM my time.
If you follow me on Twitter,
I have a,
a huge gig coming up.
Um,
and tickets will be going on sale and uh,
I gotta get my ass,
forget about physically in shape.
I've got to get my ass in shape,
uh,
comedically for this,
for this,
uh,
for this Gig.
So whatever.
That's the,
uh,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Just chicken in and you'd go fuck yourselves.
Nonaka fucking sets.
Thursday.
You have a nice weekend.
You cuts.
I'll talk to you later.
Yeah.
Advice.
Spill.
How's it going?
I hope that wherever you're read,
everything
thing is going swell.
Lol.
All right.
It's kind of a question about a relationship.
Here's my story.
I'm 19 years old,
19 year old female who's been dating a 2021 year old male and we've been
together almost five years old,
g five fucking years.
And she writes fucking ridiculous.
Uh,
fucking ridiculous.
I know.
And our relationship has had its ups and downs,
like any relationship,
but lately I feel like I can't stand them anymore.
Yeah,
that's understandable.
You've been dating.
I'm like half of your fucking life.
Um,
I don't know what's wrong with me or maybe it's him.
I don't know what's going on.
I have no fucking clue.
But he seems to have a really big problem with wheat.
If he isn't high,
he can't think about anything else but getting high.
Oh God.
Here we go.
His goal in life is to get high as a fucking kite and giggle.
That's a peaceful,
nice fucking goal.
Uh,
she writes,
what the fuck?
I don't want to be dating a weakling who needs a drug,
like who leads a drug like that.
I want a man and I don't know how to tell him that.
Every time I tell him I have a problem,
uh,
with the weed,
we get into a huge argument and I ended up being the bitch.
I just want them to care about me more than he cares about his weed and it's
hurting us financially.
We both only make 300 bucks a week and he's spending 75% of his check on weed,
cigarettes and gas.
I am the breadwinner.
I don't want to be the breadwinner.
I'm so tired of taking care of his dumb ass.
Um,
he doesn't even seem like he's willing to change even a little bit.
What do I do?
I know I probably sound like a complete prude,
but I'm not at all.
Well,
anyways,
uh,
I really hope you read this and can give me some good advice.
All right,
ma'am,
you are dating a fucking loser.
Yeah.
You're dating a loser,
so yeah,
you gotta you gotta get out of it.
I mean,
the only red flag in there is when you said,
I just want him to care about me more than he cares about his weed.
Now
the only question I have there is,
well,
what if he was really into playing guitar?
Would you then be like,
I just want him to care more about me that he does about his guitar playing?
Because then you know,
that's actually a red flag with you because you could be one of those awful
people,
like one of the worst relationships you can seriously be and is when you're
dating somebody who,
uh,
find your passion to be a threat and then they systematically,
like they try to mind fuck you out of basically either your dream in life all
the way down to just a simple hobby that you have just because it steals focus
from you paying attention to them,
which I don't think you are in this.
I think you sound very rational.
You actually said,
I don't know if it's me,
so I don't think you are being like that.
So I have to side with you 100% here.
All right,
let's fill this,
first of all,
we'll start with your relationship and just,
just completely ignore the fact that he's 21 year,
19 you've been together for five years,
which means when you got together,
you were 14,
he was 16,
which means at some point he was 18 and you are under 18.
So there was some sort of statutory rape going on there,
right?
Uh,
we'll ignore all of that and just get to the fact like,
you know,
I've been,
a lot of my listeners would probably think that I was going to trash you for you
saying that I,
I am the,
I'm the breadwinner.
I don't want to be the breadwinner,
you know,
and I,
and I would go out typical fucking broads,
you know,
they all talk about how they want to be the independent God damn woman and Yada,
Yada,
and all of a sudden they got to take care of some fucking sponge.
Welcome to my goddamn world.
I'm not,
I don't feel that's that,
that you're like that.
I know what you see a date and a fucking loser.
You're,
you're dating a future,
uh,
subject on cops.
It seems,
you know,
you,
the way you describe him,
it's his,
he shirtless to,
this guy's a fucking loser.
He makes 300 bucks a week.
I'm not judging that aspect of it,
but he spends 75% of it on weed,
cigarettes and gas.
You know,
right now I'm picturing that guy that,
uh,
Matthew mcconaughey played in dazed and confused,
just hanging around the high school,
like where the party's at,
man,
you know,
with his cool car.
Um,
yeah.
Got To get out of the relationship,
you know,
and there's nothing wrong as a female if,
if,
you know,
I'm not saying that you go out and just be a fucking gold digger,
but she wants you man to be able to provide.
That's what the fuck we do.
We provide,
we don't provide,
we're useless.
We don't have a womb right now.
Seriously,
but fucking useless.
So I,
uh,
I get it.
Yeah,
you got,
you got to break up with this guy.
You mean,
how many times can you already,
it seems like you're approaching this guy on egg shells.
You know how it'd be really nice if you,
you know,
she's just stop being a fucking loser.
You'd been,
you're not even saying that you're being a nice person.
So if I had to give you any advice,
I would say you need to get out of that relationship and considering you've been
in it since you're 14,
I think a,
you might be a little codependent and I think you need to to break up with this
guy.
Figure out who the fuck you are,
which will involve you staying single for a significant period of time.
And uh,
it,
just know that you know,
breakups are painful.
Just prepare yourself for that so you don't go running back to this fucking
loser and waste another five years of your fucking life.
Cause you don't want to go through six weeks of pain.
Just,
you know,
as they said and platoon take the pain.
All right?
Just get out of the fucking relationship and just,
just tell yourself,
this is going to suck for six weeks.
I'm going to wake up crying.
I'm going to feel lost.
I'm going to be wondering what did I used to do with all my free time before I
was with this person?
You can have that bizarre feeling where now you're looking back on somebody who
was a huge party of life and now they're becoming a stranger.
So then it just becomes this weird episode.
Like what was that?
Who was that?
What the fuck was that my life that just went into that fucking room for five
years?
It's really buzz.
Just prepare yourself that that's going to happen,
but every day it gets a little bit fucking easier.
And then one day you're gonna wake up.
You're not going to give a shit.
The Sun's going to be shining.
And uh,
and then just enjoy being single.
Your only fucking 19 years old is no fucking reason to be in a relationship
that's serious for that fucking long with the fucking loser.
So get out of it,
get through the pain.
And then after six weeks,
you know,
just hang out with your friends,
have a good fucking time,
but do not get into another relationship.
I wouldn't get into another relationship for like a year,
just be single for at least a fucking year and feel how awesome that is to just
be single,
to wake up,
you know,
feel good about yourself,
but then not have to worry that someone else's a Douche.
So that drags down.
You're feeling good about yourself quotient and just fucking be single.
All right.
They go,
I said the same thing 90 times in a fucking roll.
I realize it.
And a what do we got a little over an hour ago?
Yeah.
So good luck to your head.
Sort
of his bucket situation.
This guy got herself into,
um,
all right,
well my girlfriend is 10 years older than me.
Oh Jesus.
She has two kids
and has been married and divorced twice.
Dude,
what the fuck?
I'm 26 j says Christ college graduate.
Has any of this made any sense to any of you?
Would anybody else be out there?
26 college fucking graduate.
Have a girlfriend 10 years older than you with two kids who's been married and
divorced twice.
Good God man.
He goes,
I consider myself somewhat intelligent.
I'm sure you are,
but not in this area.
Um,
by that I mean,
you should have no problem understanding this email.
Well,
yeah,
I know everybody trashes me.
I know,
I know.
I'm the worst when it comes to reading this shit.
So anyways,
here we go.
He says,
four weeks ago I found text messages to some dude on my girlfriend's phone that
although innocent enough made it clear that whoever she was texting was on more
familiar grounds than just some work colleague or a friend,
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
is that going to be a happy ending here?
I confronted her about it and it predictably led to a lot of finger pointing.
We went back and forth and uh,
and uh,
for a few days and aired out our grievances,
but it seemed agreeable.
Now he bakes,
I guess point number two,
two oh two more weeks passed by.
And Lo and behold,
I find more text messages from the same fucking guy.
At first I tell myself,
okay,
maybe she can't break things off with this dude so quickly,
Jesus Christ,
who,
you know,
sometimes liberal thought is a,
is a great thing.
Like,
let's have a fair fucking trial for somebody before we hang them from the
nearest tree.
But then there's times it's fucking stupid.
This is just liberal thought to the,
I mean,
how much of a benefit of the doubt can you give somebody,
you know?
So he goes,
so I confront her about it and this leads to another round of finger pointing.
At which point she tells me to pack my shit and leave.
I'll do it.
I'm going to tell you right now before I read the rest of it.
That's fucking great.
You didn't have to do any dirty work.
You're out.
You're fucking up.
So anyways,
he goes,
were separated for a week when she asked me to come back and move in.
Dude,
this chick is a fucking psycho.
Here we go.
We talk about our future together,
how,
sorry she is to have done that to me,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
For Fuck Sakes.
We even talking about getting married when things finally fucking evened out.
I was full of piss and vinegar and felt vindicated,
vindicated that I was the one wronged in the whole situation and she was
actually making good by taking responsibility for what she had done through
taking responsibility would have been fucking after.
Do the second you see those weird texts?
Just get,
I'm telling you right now,
just get out of the relationship.
There isn't,
oh sorry.
Sorry about that.
Didn't know that.
That's it.
It's over.
It's fucking over.
Um,
but whatever.
You're 26 I guess you still haven't learned.
I was dumb in my 20 self.
Here we go.
Let's read the rest of this all was well and good until she didn't come home
this Thursday night,
November 11th.
She came in Friday morning with no explanation,
no apology,
no nothing.
She asked me to give her some more time,
but I decided to cut bait and just get the fuck out of this situation.
Hang on a second everybody.
Sorry.
I had to give him a little applause break there.
Of course now I'm wracked with guilt of leaving the woman I loved and lived with
for the past five fucking year.
You got what?
They're,
when you were 21,
dude,
she was 31.
Wait,
let's do the math.
She was 31.
You were 21.
She was already married twice.
All right.
This chick's is psycho and you know what that means?
She's fucking great and bed you at 21.
She fucking devastated you with fucking her pussy,
right?
Best blowjob.
You have a had.
Isn't that what happened?
And next thing you know,
you have to fucking too young and dumb me to give you fell for
Jesus Christ.
He stayed there for five fucking years.
So anyway,
I guess just Schick still calling him.
Tell him she still wants to get back together.
I feel like every time I sat up and do what I think is best for me,
she wants me back.
And every time what I do,
what's best for us as a couple,
she uses that as an opportunity to fuck with me all over again.
Yes.
Yes,
you're absolutely right.
Listen to your gut.
This guy,
see,
he knows the fucking answers.
He's,
he's listening to his gut.
Good fucking man.
Um,
is this,
is it just that chicks can handle a guy that is emotionally invested or do I
just happen to be dealing with one of those sociopath's that doesn't give a fuck
what she does so long as it suits her in the moment.
Yes.
This plenty of fucking good women.
It was not plenty of good ones.
There's good women out there.
All right.
Just like good.
A good man's hard to find this.
Finding a good woman's also difficult.
All right.
But no,
you happen to be dealing with an absolute fucking sociopath.
All right.
She had a fucked up childhood happened to her.
She got touched.
Her fucking dad took off.
I don't know.
Or She just got the fucking,
she got one of those bad brains,
you know.
Ivy,
can you tell you guys my theory on that?
The a brain,
the bee brain and the sea brain,
the brain is the genius to be brain is the uh,
oh,
he's a good fucking shit.
You know?
Fitzy and then the sea brain is your fucking mouth breathing moron.
All right.
And when it comes to being a sociopath,
that's like just a,
that's just like getting an option on the car.
All brains come with that option.
It's all available like satellite radio,
you know,
you get satellite radio in a fucking Bentley.
You can also get it my fucking Prius.
All right,
so did that make any fucking sense?
You got a sociopath with the fucking,
she could even have the a brain.
That's the sad thing about having a fucked up childhood.
She could actually be a fucking genius,
but she's got the sociopath shit.
So tell her to go call fucking doctor drew.
All right?
And you get the fuck out of the relationship.
So anyways,
he say,
I'd imagine you'd agree that I did the right thing.
Uh,
but always helps to get a little bit of press,
better perspective on it.
Dude,
I totally understand.
You've been in a five year relationship,
you're emotionally invested in this shit.
So you know what the right thing to do is,
but your emotions keep fucking with you.
All right?
So what you got to know is just look,
going through a breakup is painful.
All right?
It's not going to not be painful,
but just because it's painful,
it doesn't mean that it's not the right thing to do.
You are 100 fucking percent doing the right fucking thing.
You're 26 year old years old.
You're in the prime of your fucking life.
All right?
Get out of that situation.
Okay?
She's 10 years older than you.
By the time you're 29,
she's going to be hit and fucking menopause.
All right?
Or something like that.
Whatever.
Sliding into it.
I have no fucking idea what she's going to be doing.
She's going to be wearing those mom jeans at that point if she's not already,
which I don't think she is.
She's probably that fucking,
you know that,
uh,
that anorexic cougar look,
you know,
well,
they got a varicose vein in between their fucking,
you can see their breastplate.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
He'll stay on topic.
Yeah.
So to just get out of that,
hang out with you fucking Fellas,
you know,
hang on your buddies.
Go out and fucking have some beers.
Join a gym,
get fucking shredded.
Go out.
Start Talking Shit when you're ready.
But don't go back to that man.
You dodged a fucking bullet.
The fact that you were with her for five years and you didn't knock her up and
you got out of it,
and even after five years,
you're only 26 years old,
you made the best fucking move you're going to make.
All right.
And now this is what you need to do.
You've been in a relationship for five years.
You need to be single for at least a fucking year and a half.
And I don't mean just be single and fucking booze.
Figure out what the fuck you for.
All right?
And when you meet a girl,
if she doesn't have it,
just walk a banger in leaf.
You know,
there's nothing wrong with having a good fucking time,
but do not get sucked into another fucking relationship because you're going to,
cause you're going to have to go through this shit again.
You know,
we just sit there and you know what's fucking wrong,
but you don't want to go through the fucking pain of it and you keep coming
back.
It's a fucking nightmare.
Good for you,
sir.
I'm fucking proud of you.
He did the right thing.
You SORTA fucking wavering cause you're going through the motions.
You're only 26 she got with her when you were 21 is probably your first major
fucking break up.
So it's acceptable that you fucked up and went back that second time.
But do not go back again.
And if any of your fucking friends are listening to this,
don't let them do that shit.
All right.
It's time to a bucket bar stool and stop it.
[inaudible]
to Yankee pictures in 1973 I never heard of this traded their wives and kids,
they just switched off families.
And this is the story.
According to the Daily News,
1973,
um,
Fort Lauderdale,
Florida.
March,
March 5th Yankee Pitcher,
they call by their last names here because I guess you know,
people know who the fuck they were checking.
H and Maryland disclosed today that they had an exchange families several months
ago.
Peterson moving in with Susan Keck.
Rich enter two daughters and Keck rich moving in with Maryland.
Peterson enter two sons.
The pictures in separate talks said they decided to reveal the arrangement
because too many people knew about it.
Evidently everybody in baseball,
I mean you can't really keep a story like that quiet I guess all around the
fucking spring training.
Everybody was talking about the shit.
So they finally just went public with it.
So,
um,
they thought it was time to clear the air and the 31 year old Peterson confided
that they hope that you won't make anything sorted out of this according to
Kekich.
I'm sure I'm saying that wrong.
Unless people know the full details that could turn out to be a nasty type
thing.
Don't say this was wiped swapping wife swapping because it wasn't,
we didn't swap wives.
We swapped lives.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Look at this guy fucking sprinkling a bunch of sugar over it.
Um,
I guess technically he is right dude.
How fucked up or their children
jacket.
You Dad just taps out.
Yeah,
I'm Outta here.
I don't want to be with your mom anymore.
And you know,
you know my best buddy,
he was always over here drinking beers.
Yeah,
he's going to be a dad now.
He's going to be banging your mom when you hear that Mona just,
no,
that's not me doing that work or right kids and uh,
I'm Outta here.
Uh,
Duh.
I'm going to go fuck his wife and go raise his children.
Okay.
How does that sit with you?
Jesus Christ.
You want to talk about if they had daughters,
you want to talk about the easiest chicks to lose your fucking virginity to the,
there you go.
Right there.
There they are.
One I'm up fellas.
All right.
New Jersey where the forehead resided for four years requires simply that the
parties proved separation for a year in order to file for divorce.
It's a no fault rule,
meaning no grounds are required.
You know what's amazing about this fucking story is how like that you could
actually keep something like this quiet for a,
for a couple of months.
Because if you ever tried to do any bullshit like this,
uh,
today,
I mean Jesus Christ,
three different 24 hour sports networks and ESPN alone.
The first is network.
I mean,
then you got TMZ would jump up that would just TMC late night talk shows.
They got like 58 of them now.
Oh my God,
it'd be over manager.
Ralph Houk said it was a situation that he could live with a,
that it would not rip apart his team and that it still had its best chance of
winning a pennant since 1964.
I always like Ralph Elk fucking kept it positive.
Uh,
just for the record,
they went 80 and 80 to two games of under 500.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Jesus Christ.
How the fuck he is the top that obscure staff
[inaudible]
that's plow ahead.
Oh,
by the way,
I've really pissed off a lot of potheads.
Evidently on my podcast.
They think that I,
I am against smoking weed and then I'm trashing that whole fucking lifestyle.
Why don't you guys go take another head off your fucking blunt and fucking
relax.
All right.
Just because I,
I trashed that guy
who was a pot smoker.
I wasn't saying that weed was a bad thing.
All right.
At this point with those vaporizers that they have,
it's probably fucking 10 times healthier than sitting around drinking a six
pack.
I don't have a fucking problem.
I wasn't talking about smoking weed.
I was,
I wasn't,
I was making fun of a loser.
I was telling that woman that she was dating a fucking loser.
All right.
As a man,
your job is to go out and fucking provide,
you know,
and when somebody breaks into your house not to shit yourself and to grab the
nearest blunt object and fucking go brave harder on him,
that's what you're supposed to do.
You know me,
I would shit myself,
lock myself in the bathroom and called nine one one of course,
but I can provide,
goddammit.
It's when I got a fifth fucking pit bull for,
um,
speaking of that,
I watched no country for old men again,
man,
what a fucking awesome movie that is.
That is just absolutely phenomenal fucking movie.
It actually made me sad that we were in final descent.
That's how good that goddamn movie is.
Um,
but anyways,
so I just know that potheads I'm not making fun.
You know,
if I make fun of some guy who's a booze bag,
booze bag,
fucking losers sitting around drinking bear all day on the couch,
that doesn't mean that I don't think that anybody should drink.
All right.
Yeah.
So fucking relax.
Jesus Christ.
I thought you got mellow when you smoke weed.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead.
Hey Paul,
can you guys basically just admit that you want weed to be free just so you can
just sit around,
smoke it,
and not have to worry about anybody hassle and yeah.
You know,
to use a classic Hippie word,
why can't you just admit that and stopped telling me about,
you know,
how the fucking declaration of independence was written on hemp and all,
all these,
you know,
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
she can make a potted plant out of a 40 and an empty 40 ounce.
I'm not going to sit there and act like I don't wish that I,
I want to drink in public.
Right?
Dude,
my brain shut down seven minutes ago.
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
I need to start reading again.
[inaudible].